you know you know what's [__] crazy
you reminded me of this because you said
that you're like talking about carrying
an iPad or whatever MH I ran with Jeff
last Sunday yeah we ran 20 miles
together because it was his [__] idea
he texted me he was like you want to go
for a long run I was like for sure he's
like what are you how far are you
running and he was like I was I'm
supposed to do 20 so I was like okay I
guess that kind of Whit Me In Shape a
little bit mentally I was like I have to
do 22 cuz the race is four weeks away so
I'm like I got to [__] get my ass
into gear so then I pull up and I'm like
okay we're doing 20 right and he's like
what he's like you want to do 20 I was
like you this is your idea you said this
and he was like oh man I must have been
on a sleeping pill or something like I
don't remember saying that and I was
like okay well we're doing it and he was
like okay he did the whole thing
carrying a water bottle a phone and he
was wearing a cotton aim Leon door shirt
nice the whole thing all 20 miles nice I
couldn't [__] believe it he pulled up
in front of me I was like are you
wearing a designer shirt right now he's
like yeah cotton t-shirt yeah he's like
yeah am I [__] I don't know he killed it
20 mies so la it really is we got to get
you like Silk running wear man silk yeah
that'd be kind of nice yeah cuz you get
the cha yeah my nipples are bad what do
you think that is is that like I lube
them up though now do you actually yeah
yeah I do like light moment in my closet
before I leave or I squirt this um
shammy butter onto my and I go like
this
for a bit too long
yeah Xbox record
that Xbox record that
again damn dude it's been a while since
somebody talked to their XBox I
think just watch your Xbox just like
Xbox record
[Laughter]
that [__] what was that called Xbox
Connect yeah uh the one did you talk to
did you have did you need the connect to
talk to it I never had an Xbox yeah I
never had an Xbox oh yeah I was an Xbox
guy I had to connect because you know
remember when that was cool as a
programmer what yeah I'm going to buy a
connect and maybe see if I can uh write
some software for that [__] sat in a box
I borked it
yeah I borked it how'd the connect
hacking go this weekend oh I bricked it
yeah I tried to install a girl a new
operating operating system and I I I
fried it so M yeah it's all
borked yeah dude that's a good word
right bork yeah yeah it's fun to say if
you finish early
guys oh I borked I borked that one I
guess well let me go down on
you I borked that one I guess B that too
I guess bro I read a fake post last
night about um like a swinger couple
okay but man it was written so funny me
and my wife have been married for 14
years we went out for drinks for my
birthday in July we always wanted to try
a threesome and tonight was the night we
met a college guy that that's we hit it
off with and we went to our place we
were pretty drunk I sat down and watched
them start and played with myself the
guy was about 5'5 or so whenever
whenever says when somebody says played
with myself
I always just picture like slapping
someone like slapping their own dick
around not just box smack on their leg
not just doing the salmon yeah to with
myself yeah
yeah yeah th woring themselves yeah
cat's
cradle chasing their own ass
yeah that' be some
like yeah just [__] yeah just so I
played with myself
trying to suck their own dick sucking
his man uh the dog version of that's the
human version of chasing your own tail
sucking your own dick trying to suck
your own dick and like doing somersaults
yeah what's really funny I saw on
Twitter someone was um making fun of
that when Elon was rolling out the
feature of blocking your uh likes yeah
yeah this person goes oh I'm so glad my
likes are private now no one can see my
likes and you know obviously I go check
them and it's just dudes with dicks so
long they can suck their own
dicks it's just a guy like
this like the [__] look
like wait there's multiple of these M
how do you even find multiple of those
on Twitter I don't know but I was just
crying laughing that's really good dude
it it looked like just a bunch of guys
like like kissing a doorknob like just
like so it's dudes with dicks so long
they don't even have to like really bend
over no yeah it was hilarious I've never
seen a human position like that like it
wasn't like you know we joke this this
is us telling on ourselves we think
about having
to yeah ex these guys were just
like man that would suck yeah I would
hate to have that ability what's really
crazy is they were all really short too
they were like that's why it worked like
they had small spines and you know it
could have been optical illusion those
guys could had 4-in penises and they
could have been like three five I don't
know that's true yeah that is true but
it just really funny cuz they just
dropped their head down a little
bit so anyway back to this
story we were drunk I sat down and
watched them start and I and played with
myself the guy was about five 5'5 or so
so we were surprised yeah you're really
giving it to her over there you're
really borking her so we were surprised
when she pulled him out how owed he was
and my heart dropped oh I watched her
take it for a while uh she clearly was
enjoying
it
yeah yeah yeah well she's really having
[Laughter]
fun she's just like babe you're not
wiggling your fingers is something
[Laughter]
wrong no everything's
fine
after I came I guess postn Clarity
kicked in and I was full of regret she e
this is a crazy ass
line she even tasted his [__] after I
told her beforehand that was a no
no that's a
bummer that's a
bummer wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait
wait I like how he said that's a no no
babe are you okay you've hardly salmon
your
thigh babe are you okay you've hard
you've hardly cradled the
cat dude so there don't taste this
[Laughter]
Cal no no no it doesn't taste good this
is supposed to be
fun you've ruined salmoning for me
bro uh there's a brutal line in here
that I can't see but it was this is
almost
verbatim the worst part was right before
she orgasmed she grabbed my hand and
said something's going to
happen oh isn't that and he was like
she's never hit the Big
O from penetration with
me but this is fake though fake okay
okay but I was crying laughing dude
imagine dude
imagine something's going to
happen I've never felt this before what
is
this just looking him straight in the
eye this is amazing and she's
like honey this is the best feeling I've
ever felt in my entire
life please help me through
this
yeah yeah no definitely this is the best
salmon I've ever done yeah it's it's
just going to be best I've ever salmon I
love
salmoning dude some of the comments
killed me one of them was like uh [__]
around and found out literally LOL yeah
yeah that's his wife now I think that
dude that's the college guy's wife now
yeah yeah that college gu is
married my
wife my wife damn sad yeah you got
tooo